worries over recession and oversupply
have continued to push Global oil prices
down days after Western countries
introduced new rules to cap the price of
Russian crude
the price of global Benchmark Brent
crude oil remained around 77 a barrel as
of Thursday morning that's the lowest
price since January the new cap on
Russian oil introduced by the European
Union in G7 Nations began Monday but
several major importers including India
and China have signaled they'll pay it
little attention
earlier today I asked our Delhi
correspondent whether India will
continue buying more Russian oil
retards absolutely unlikely to change
Stephen uh fundamental who's been
articulating India's policy ever since
the Ukraine War Began has said it in as
many words that India is not uh going to
reduce buying oil from Russia in fact
just yesterday he said that in
Parliament uh that while the government
does not ask companies to buy oil from
specific locations it does make sense
for companies to buy the oil from where
they are getting the best deal in the
interest of the Indian people so that's
as much as about the government's
policies concerned the oil companies are
also Towing the government's line and uh
India in any case is yet to adhere to
the oil price cap Stephen
all right so Indy wants to go where
prices are best at the same time we know
that there's going to be more pressure
from Western Nations especially when
those prices climb again and it makes a
difference how difficult a situation
could that be for India to navigate
well Stephen ever since the Ukrainian
Invasion began we've seen that Western
Nations have seen have been upset with
India's continued trade links and this
purchase of oil from Russia but India
has continued to uh hold very firmly
it's its position on the issue and there
there is no indication that India is
likely to change its stunts the Western
pressure appears to be cooling off
because as German foreign minister and
Elena badbach was here in India recently
and during her exchanges with the Press
there was no indication whatsoever about
any Western pressure on India as far as
Russia is concerned her statement before
coming to India in fact carried some
signals but after coming back there was
no statement virtually so that's some
kind of an uh indication that the
Western pressure you know appears to be
cooling off as far as India is concerned
Stephen
my colleague Charo cartsuke in Delhi
there and staying with the price cap
officials in the U.S and UK say that
they're speaking to counterparts in
Turkey to resolve a traffic jam of oil
tankers in that country's Waters but
turkey has demanded that shippers
provide a new proof of insurance
following the introduction of the cap
which again prohibits Western insurers
from covering Russian crude at more than
60 dollars a barrel
the US and UK say the Turkish check is
unnecessary under the new rules
cormick McGary is associate director of
the consultancy control risks in Paris
he joins me now Cormac thanks for coming
on the show why is turkey conducting
these checks if other nations are saying
that they're actually superfluous
well Stephen turkey is following its uh
logical strategic position uh both
politically and geographically in the
context of this conflict so turkey in
effect is carrying out the will of the
G7 and the European Union with this uh
60 price cap uh by uh using its choke
point in the Black Sea I.E the boss for
a straight to say yes we can enforce the
will of the G7 and the European Union uh
decision on Russia because we have full
control of the the Russian Fleet that
leaves the Black Sea at the same time
keeping itself in that strategic
position to be a friend of Russia while
also being a friend of of the West in
regards to the price cap
at the same time many of these ships are
now having to scramble seemingly for
insurance
um how hard of a market is that when
many Western insurers have now been
taken off the table essentially
well fundamental to the teeth of of the
60 price cap is the fact that Maritime
insurance is is pretty much grounded in
the west there are only 13 individual
um p i clubs which is effectively
Maritime Insurance of those 13 UH 60 of
them are in the UK and those and the
rest are basically in Norway Sweden U.S
and Japan so that is that is the market
for maritime insurance so when it comes
to enforcing the 60 price cap that is
the tooth that the West has
um and to make it happen so where did
the rest of the vessels go to get
insurance that's the question and that
effectively is why turkey is able to
stop at the last count at least 19
vessels on Monday uh have been stopped
by Turkey
um because they have nowhere else to go
for insurance that easily
it sounds like Russia might then just
develop its own insurance Market is is
that a possibility
it's not just a possibility but there is
a precedent for it and an actual fact of
Russian
Russia has uh an effect of parastatal uh
Maritime Insurance uh group
um ingosttracker and this already exists
they're already underwrite about 2 000
ships uh which is relatively small in
the global market but that allows them
the groundwork for Russia to grow a more
domestic Maritime insurance or pni Club
itself and indeed what we may see over
the coming year a big impact on the
insurance world as a result of the price
cut is the proliferation of Maritime
Insurance away from that kind of Western
and london-centric model into other
countries because indeed it's not just
Russia that wants to export this oil
there is about half the world that does
not necessarily agree with or care about
the uh the price cap that wants to
consume that oil so there's a lot of
demand for an additional Insurance
Market
all right Cormac McGarry with control
risks in Paris thank you very much
thank you very much Stephen